hello and welcome once again to gamespot
of Thrones I'm Lucy joined this week by
Dave do it hello and tomorrow saying
hello newcomer to the show you excited
to be very excited we had a interesting
episode bit of a bit of a man episode
but before we get into it there we're
gonna be delving deep into this week's
episode so season 6 episode 6 blood of
my blood you haven't watched it what are
you doing here go watch it because they
were going to be spoilers aplenty but if
you did catch the episode last night
let's get into it this episode I guess
they were trying to give us a little
time to you know get over the emotional
rollercoaster that was last week but
there was a bunch of filler in this one
uh at least it was bookended by like the
good bits um but before we get there
tomorrow what happened across the Narrow
Sea in a sauce so in Essos aria is still
on her assassination mission and she's
still watching a reenactment play and
sold out yeah she's really enjoying
she's well into it she starts off
getting a good chuckle out of seeing
Joffrey's poison scene which we all
loved obviously when she gets to see
Lady cranes powerful acting which kind
of in raptures her and like the emotion
of it kind of stirs some emotion within
her it kind of reminds of what she's
lost and almost like is a call back to
her original quest for revenge from
there she goes backstage carrying on her
mission to poison lady crane and puts
the poison in there but on her way out
accidentally runs into lady crane and
never build a heart-to-heart and they
discussed like you know acting and how
they did you know change the script how
she change it and yea lady cranes like
really nice and like charming and warm
in the way a mother is which is
something Aria hasn't had in a really
really long time but yeah she kind of
leaves off and during the whole time you
see Bianca in the background who's and
it's kind of implied she's she's the one
who put the mock out on Lady crane Oh
[ __ ] beyond yeah so then after that we
cut to a backstage with all the actors
kind of milling around and lady cranes
about to take the sip of the drink
that's poison and at the
foreal a second arias lepcha out of her
hand saves her careful that one and yeah
kind of screws up her assassination
mission like if she was playing hit man
she'd be really bad I ok awful so lady
cranes not getting killed unfortunately
for Aria the waif is hanging around in
the background keeping an eye on her and
she reports straight back to you can hey
girl snitches straight away knocks on
arias straight away and yakking haga
gives her the command to take out aria
you promised me
don't let yourself so the next scene
we've got a aria taking needle out of
its hiding place going into a dark room
blowing out the candles and presumably
just kind of getting comfortable for the
impending assassination attempt yeah
what's weird though is like in the
Faceless Men you know they're trying to
make you forget who you are and
everything um and I is not allowed to
hold on to her grudges like her list
whereas the wife has had it in five it
seems like day one and yet jack is just
like yeah I keep just you know keep that
on the back burner and then now it's
like I'm gonna kill her that's just an
interesting observation because a lot of
people are probably thinking she spent
Aria spent a lot of time kind of cutting
ties to her old life going through his
brutal training she went blind and now
she seems like at the very last moment
she's given up on the entire thing and
is going back to her quest unless
killing wife is part of her trial what
and then she can use the waves face
maybe maybe cuz it seems like going back
to the original revenge quest after
having gone through all that it's just
like an unexpected jarring turn for her
well the end you see her in a darkened
room and she she was blind for ages and
so maybe that's the whole plot of how
she's gonna fight the way fuse the like
take her senses away now she's been
trained to fight blind get the one up on
her but if they went through like the
same training has the wife never been
blind do we know oh no it doesn't I mean
maybe it's like generic training for all
like maybe it's specific to Aria like
she needs to stop seeing her past before
she can move forward maybe it's like
symbolic so and maybe the wave had some
different drama so yeah I mean to be
honest I felt a lot of the plot points
in this episode were quite heavy handed
like especially Sam's who will get into
in a minute but this one it was kind of
like a nice subtle one that left a lot
of questions I thought meanwhile in
murine we have naris with her newly
acquired khalasar just riding behind her
they're just kind of sauntering along
she keeps getting them and then
losing them yeah another one who knows
how long they'll be around for but like
she's walked she's on the horse going
down and she kind of has spider sense
tingling she sees something in a
distance or feel something in a distance
and then at that time her right hand man
Dario is like what you up to and she's
like you know what I want to go and
conquer the Seven Kingdoms how many
ships would I need to do that and he's
like there were 1000 just like the exact
amount that your own greater life stops
was like hmm build me one thousand one
thousand ships in 10 days please in an
island that has no tree so then she's
like well I figure that bit out
meanwhile just need to go to the toilet
or something like she goes around the
corner it's like everyone's like all
right piss break knows what's going on
here my favorite thing is is when
Dario's like I'm gonna go after her we
start I go mate no no covered every team
going its a broiling 10 like Nev it but
then she's obviously we all set it's
going on just long enough for us to
figure out what happens and then the
shadow of a dragon appears and there you
have it go go on his back and he's like
I'm a dragon still you guys and
everyone's that world dragon but then
she gives that speech and in every hole
time dragons got his mouth open I keep
thinking like is he kind of like birdie
fire since she went on a horse horse is
like nowhere now no was lunch by the way
drag on if I fancy a snack I brought you
one that's my favorite part if you
watching that again look at the horses
faces they're like we're gonna eat in
way we're dead we're done here oh yeah I
mean for an episode called blood of my
blood I expected more from the dinero's
bits but apparently not but speaking of
the actual I guess the meat of the
episodes in terms of family ties was
horn Hill Dave what happened in horn
Hill and the rest of the South
considering the amount of time this
episode spent in horn Hill not what
happened yes and the carriage and Sam is
just narrowing about nature and trees
then it's a nice tree over there we're
low through some maples and willows and
the baby little salmon his arms is just
like being a horrible pervert we just
say shout-out to that be he was like
hands out staring at you know and we get
to horn Hill meet Sam's mother and
sister and again
he's just like straight in goddamn the
point whether like his mum leans FB
today was like all right he leans
forward like yep I'm gonna die I'm
coming in and so we hanging on horn hill
me the mother meet the sister and we've
been led to believe that you know Sam's
dad is a complete ass and well he isn't
that he's an ass so we should we sit
through the most awkward dinner ever he
thinks that being a member of the Nights
Watch was going to make a man out of him
in a twig and Kili accidentally let slip
that she's a wildling and classic Gilly
apparently he's not a big fan of
wildlings ah so that spoils dinner mmm
spend a lot of time at this table and
eventually Sam is preparing to leave and
gillies gonna stay behind work in the
kitchen little Sam's going to get an
education and then we see him leave him
like a classic Sam no backbone then it
comes back yes sam and then he Rob's his
his dad's sword hmm so it's one of the
few remaining Valyrian steel sword so
its heart heart bane yeah um it's kind
of setting up Sam to be this white
Walker killer which is quite interesting
is it like weird he's killed one before
yeah and hippies if he's taking this
balloon steel and we've seen how
powerful it is back to the wall with him
if he ends up back there then who's
gonna be glad he snatched that yeah cuz
he's had the only one or two ways he's
only gonna go back to the wall with it
blaring steel or he's getting her to old
town and cure Jorah any come to maester
with all his healings chop his arm off
cured get got done well moving a little
more south to King's Landing Marjorie
has been brainwashed I think it's fair
to say Oh has she well it'sit's implied
it seems to be that she's now a devotee
the gods and and Tommen seems to share
the same views as them now they they
seem very pious and Marjorie's putting
quite a strong religious persona on I
love by the way I love when when she's
getting Tommen around a little finger
like she has a little like a way about
her just a Rico pettish like coy way
that she acts and I love it so
manipulative it's embeddable did feel
like
be kind of like who is this my dream
whooshing oh I'm so stupid Oh Tom and
forgive me we all think that she's going
to start doing her walk of atonement
that's what it's been building up to and
the Tyrell troops obviously feel the
same they're coming up to the to face
the high Sparrow at the bottom of the
steps we see mace Tyrell in the greatest
hat we've seen Game of Thrones and he
delivers it bless him he tries to
deliver a stirring speech he like it's a
foreign yeah give us give it up man
these guys are just here to get gold he
cuts to Jamie who's probably delivered a
few speeches and he's like or I mate
let's go so that it seems like we're
building up to fight the men of the
faith mm-hmm and Marjorie status stop
sat at the top of stairs building
building building and then all of a
sudden as far as like as no good not
gonna be a walk by the way I've just
brainwashed Tom and really taking his
backbone and throw it into the sea at
this point and now you see all of his
Kingsguard are now wearing the symbol of
the faith and they're all the faith
militant and now guarding him and we see
the true like that the faith and the
crown are now one and the queen of
thorns says it we failed and there's
high Sparrow delivers like one of the
greatest shit-eating grins of all oh
he's like I did it you lose me a
shit-eating grin might be better if he
actually had to wash those yeah although
I did love watching Marjorie's face
because she obviously had her own plan
about how things are gonna go down and
then she sees Tyrol troops and she just
is like clearly had no idea they were
coming so she's like okay I mean this is
a win-win for me either way so Jamie at
this point is not pleased he gets fired
from the Kingsguard you just see him
stripped of his armor and then he's sent
away to Riverrun to take take the castle
back but first we see him talking with
Cersei they say they have our son
basically because the sparrows
brainwashed him and there's more awkward
flirting making out surprising meanest
angry surprise before Jamie goes off to
get Bronn again he's got the whole plan
of assassination but he's gonna go hang
out in a river run to try and take take
on the blackfish no mention of dawn
thank the gods we're all good with that
I mean we're like five episodes in a row
now without any any dawn but I'll take
the north so North is pretty much where
like most of the exciting stuff happened
i think this we
we're back at the twins we could see
walder frey who is being his own usual
charming self he's not very happy
because the blackfish who is brendan
Tully has managed to take river run back
out from under free control so he's
telling his sons you know god damn it go
up there take that castle back but his
sons is like we can't you know brinton
Tully the blackfish he's got a big army
now and there is a great name drop for
the Brotherhood without banners saying
that they are raiding all our like food
supplies at burning villages this isn't
going well for us we can't win the
Tully's of Riverrun you could hold out a
siege for about a year we can't do it so
I don't know then Walter decides to
bring out his ace in the hole or his ace
in the dungeon Edmure Tully's back here
uploaded mirror is knowing how we know
that Littlefinger fed that information
about Riverrun to Sansa and we all
thought like oh that could be a little
finger plot it could just be a trap but
by not so also a little finger and EDD
Mia grew up together so it could be that
he's his mole mmm like what's
interesting I don't know but north of
the wall we got some answers so as we
said last week Mira's dragging bran bran
can't control his green seen dreams he
has you know just this this array of
visions he gets to see Mad King eros and
the burn the mall which we assume that
he would see he also sees and catlins
murder the red wedding he is all over
the place and then they get attacked by
little abominations I guess they're not
like why blinded by the whites and just
the last minute come riding in on a
horse set stuff on fire kills more cold
hands here we now have confirmation that
cold hands at least in the show is
Benjen stark so brands uncle which is
exciting and we got to see how he was
made because he's like a half white
Walker half-human but we'll talk more
about cold hands in a little bit but he
also mentions another little nugget of
information that bran is definitely the
three-eyed Raven now
yep but he likes it or not he's the frio
Draven I'll be the old man in the tree
yeah tough three-eyed Raven sent for me
bread Ravens dead no he lives again so
an interesting revelation about cold
hands maybe it's one question that's
been answered but this this episode I
felt did raise a few more questions
particularly to do with De Niro sat i'm
gone' take this one yeah tenaris is it's
she's in a strange place right now she
seems to be regressing into an older
character someone who we haven't seen
for a long time this is the first time
in quite a few seasons I think that
she's talking about wanting to conquer
westeros and take over the the kingdom's
again that that was something that her
brother kind of imposed on her yeah and
then it was something that her husband
Drogo wanted to gift her for her son but
since they're kind of out of the picture
now it's kind of unclear why she wants
that again she's become more of a
liberator than a conqueror so the fact
that she's like suddenly like I want to
own the you know we're gonna have all of
it is quite jarring and it's a bit
sudden how many ships will I need to
bring my colors out to Westeros the
rocky and all their horses can solid
second son's a thousand ships easily
probably more and who has that money
nobody nobody yet so we ride from the
rain and after that we sail for Westeros
and what then I take what is mine you
weren't made to sit on a chair and a
palace what was I needful you're a
conqueror denounced on one her demeanor
has changed quite a bit she's usually
quite sympathetic tool to the people
she's talking to whereas when she was
addressing her khalasar she almost was
channeling Khal Drogo like if you go
back and watch the two speeches hmm it's
very similar and it's like he was
talking about riding horses across the
the kingdom's and you know raping and
pillaging and doing what doth Iraqis do
best and she's kind of leaning towards
that as well which is kind of a stray
I'm not sure if it's it feels
inconsistent to me but i'm not sure if
it does to you guys would you think
about that without her son and kind of
like Khal Drogo and her brother is just
kind of in line with what she is as a
character or is it kind of weird to you
guys I think no I think it's consistent
in a way by think the way that it came
out of this up so does maybe a little
heavy-handed because she's always been
me sir she's the breaker of chains
marula which has always been you know
the generis that we sort of expected but
I think her being captured and put in
the dosh cleaners meant to symbolize
that you know she's had enough and now
she just properly wants to get over
there to Westeros it's also quite nice
because God she can't just be stuck in a
sauce for the rest of the damn series
which is what I was genuinely worried
about happening see to me like it seems
like it almost feels so strange like so
jarring attend that it's a bit crazy and
as we all know craziness runs in the
Targaryen family like her father is Mad
King Aerys yeah and her brother is like
he was crazy in terms of his lust for
power yeah so this could be a sign of
kind of like that same Targaryen madness
trying to take over her I hope so and if
that's the case like so far all the
Targaryen who have given in to their
madness have ended in failure or death
which means like they could be sign up
Daenerys to be the big bad when she gets
over there with a dragon everyone's like
she's kind of awful maybe we should take
care of her as well I mean she's
bringing the Dothraki with her and her
daughter aki on exactly political like
they don't their mo is to kill
everything still destroy steel horses
like just degrade and you know it's like
running a train across the entirety of
Westeros it's not going to be any room
for people to be like yeah you know this
kind of like shades of you know
benevolence here it's straight-up murder
it's not gonna be a peaceful takeover
like yours named Irene like but you
proved that change but like weeds a
burner some Westeros yeah it's gonna be
quite stranger because then you imagine
if she ends up meeting John whereas
John's kind of like on the on the
revenge kick as well so these characters
that we've grown to love and think are
the you know the nice ones they just
want honor and peace might not be maybe
they're kind of like play off each other
one will be the in
the gung-ho mad you know warmonger the
other ones like you listen we have an
objective but we got to be careful you
know the people that we love her and
they are humans about so maybe John's
going to be like the war on her fire or
the ice on her phone hmm bran can't
control his green seeing I think also I
love the fact that this episode was
directed by jack bender who did a bunch
of episodes of lost so when Brown was
having that crazy vision thing I'll say
oh this is so series for of loss we have
to go back we have to go back and back
he did go so Dave you've been through
brands vision it was a lot of chopping
and changing but you've seen some quite
interesting things they do flash flash
back quite sporadically but there are
some quite interesting moments and if
you put them all in in order so most
interesting of all is that we is the
first time we see the Mad King himself
and he's just shouting burn them all you
see shots of wildfire which is played a
big part of the series in the past mmm
bright green yeah it's pretty obviously
wildfire yeah just big green flames
murder in loads of dudes then we see
shots of King's Landing in smoke so not
sure if that's like before forward or
after here or in like when he burned the
rebels yeah and then we see Jamie take
his famous action of stabbing him in the
back and then takes a seat of throne for
himself maybe just because he's tired
because he's no king yeah arm is heavy
yeah it's just like oh man this seat
although he did you steal an old dude
yeah don't think it was that difficult
he also gets to witness the death of his
brother his father and his mother he
wasn't there for any of those no no he
was way way away yeah so he knows
they're all dead but he's it's the first
time he's like obviously seen it lots of
shots of the night King as well hmm at
the head of his army at hardhome they
took over all the white head of the
wildlings yeah when he raises the dead
they're all staring off as they the few
flee across the lake touching the face
of the the baby that we saw a long time
ago and turning it you see his eyes turn
turn blue I do wonder about that baby
though I feel like it's gonna have some
it's gonna come back yeah
some point they're reminding us for a
reason yeah scores of the undead the
moment he touched brands arm and kind of
ruined their little underground tree den
that they all had it's like you know
when you do something embarrassing and
at night you SAT there going I remember
I did that I can't believe I did that
that is essentially what our brands
vision was is like mm the time I just
destroyed Westeros because I was an
idiot doomed a species to extinction and
then we even see the fight that the
night King had with brands brother John
obviously another no way he has any
knowledge of that shots of Danny with
the Dragons as well his own fall from
the tower and what appears to be young
Ned's hand covered in blood hmm so r
plus early cuz Jake well there's the
shots of wildfire the Mad King shouting
the White Walkers do we think this
confirms another theory we're talking
about where brands whispers into the
past are affecting way more than we
thought yeah good yeah it looks like
that's what they leaning towards I mean
the Mad King Aerys thing burn the mall
is obviously the thing that people
really focus on was you know was that
brand kind of whispering in his ear
telling him to burn the White Walkers or
and he's missing two hook revels yeah
burn every one killer run I think the
opposite equals J thing is like if you
look closer at that shot there's clearly
like I think if we go back and watch the
scene at the Tower of joy you can
probably make out that that is
definitely Ned Stark yes bracer yeah and
there looks like a woman's hand
underneath but it looks like the babies
have been cut out like that's is that a
I mean cesarean section possibly yeah
yeah but like why was it a difficult
birth was it someone knew the real
parentage of the baby poison get the kid
out of ya mother can die that's all we
know right like that he went to tower of
joy and there was blood and promise me
Ned promise me and there are a lot of
shots in this do you think many more are
kind of hinting a future plot lines like
the night Kings march or even lady stone
Huck's we do see or cattle and get her
throat cut now that could have just been
for context and these are the family
dying or it could be hinting at
something I think because later on the
episode when they go to the twins
they make a real big deal about Walder
rivers who is the one who actually cut
the throat and I feel like this is all
sort of just reminding everyone of what
happened like why the Tully's want
revenge why the Starks want revenge and
also may be seeding lady's door not
because she's it definitely feels like a
lot of the flashback stuff and a lot of
the references that I've been made I
kind of just playing everyone towards
reminding you about Caitlyn stock so
that when she comes back people like
going like what the hell's this all
about yeah it's definitely feels like
set up for that but like you said before
it's it's implied that it's the
Brotherhood of that banners that raised
her and we mentioned before that the
Brotherhood without banners are raiding
the supply lines hmm for the Walder's
that are assaulting Riverrun and we are
like we see the scene where he says um
show them the knife that cut catlin
starts throat who's currently leading
the Brotherhood of banners uh it'll be
beric Dondarrion because they have
source of my but depending on whether or
not Lady Stoneheart back she actually
does take control of the Brotherhood so
she if she's been brought back she's the
one leading them getting revenge on the
phrase if she's not then it's beric
Dondarrion and they have some history
with people returning from the dead and
that kind of stuff right yeah barrack
has been brought by seven times so and
after all the time travel stuff the
raising the dead stuff the half white
Walker cold hand stuff I always thought
that bringing back ladies don't hurt
from the day would be like oh that's a
bit too far-fetched it's like the least
farfetch ya know what happened now it's
fine alright cold hands so for years
what creatures have been speculating
about who he could be so could obviously
Benjen stark is the the obvious choice
the night's watchman who went missing
who's then come back as cold hands but
there's also other names in the mix like
old like really old Nights Watch members
who have just gone missing like
literally hundreds of years ago it could
be them but now it seems that the
showrunners so at least for the TV show
cold hands is benjamin stock
in the book we know that he's definitely
member the Nights Watch because he's
dressed in black and he meets Sam Tarly
in the book at some points it calls him
brother again saying that he's remember
the Nights Watch so it's kind of strange
that he has been confirmed as benjin
because there was a thing I saw where
someone had found an original manuscript
of a dance of dragons and they had
editors notes written on them and one of
the editors notes was so cold hands is
benjin ? and George wrote in big red pen
no like circled it so it will be
interesting to see if this is a plot
point they're gonna deviate on hmm I
mean previous to this hold the holder
stuff hasn't reaches finale in in the
books has it George has confirmed that
came from right so this would be the
first plot deviation right not really
like I think if it was a big character
reveal like sometimes characters get
change around right the reason I was
thinking is because we know benjin as a
character like we met him in season one
he's Ned's brother he took John to the
wall is it just convenience that he's
cold hands I mean is part convenience
but also makes good sense like obviously
been jeans a known quantity he's like he
went missing for a period and he has
familiarity and has been in close
contact with the White Walkers so if it
was gonna be anyone it like he's the
best option I think and it kind of fits
the way the story is actually going it's
not like he's shoehorned in there
because obviously at the same time you
know brand is seeing the visions and a
lot of the visions are of his family
being killed which is something he
didn't really see because he wasn't
present but it might be a way of kind of
reinforcing his family kind of
connection again yeah to remind him that
he is you know a relative of benjin to
kind of create that connection maybe as
a replacement photo I mean how did
they've always been taught quite close
play he needs someone who he can rely on
again and for that person like I think
the best person is his uncle Benjen that
is interesting and she's saying that
reinforcing the family time because
especially now that benjin like oh yeah
the three-eyed Raven is you and last
week the three our aprons like oh I'm
training you to be my replacement
it's kind of as if bran was his own
entity rather than being bran stark he's
becoming a three-eyed Raven yeah this
all seeing it makes for the best
storytelling as well because if it was
some old dude it's been missing a
hundred years ago who saved brownie be
like why do I yeah well yeah and there's
a lot more kind of gravitas to being Ben
junt because obviously his brother's
been killed all of his family have been
killed so he's got this real kind of
need to help his nephew and kind of see
things through and get rid of the White
Walkers and you know who knows where
they could go on from there they go
conquer the world and obviously since
he's half white Walker and the White
Walkers are trapped north of the wall
because of the walls magic yeah maybe he
can now come south again yeah yeah and
like imagine that reunion with with John
like yeah oh by the way I died once and
came back to life oh hi uncle Benjen
you're half a white Walker yeah like
that's that's Emerson like a
supernatural family stuff going on yeah
he could be the key to defeating you
know the wild walkers he's party now
he's got one funny 12 and he could like
come in between and be like the key to
figuring out how to bring them down once
and for all and he knows what he's doing
he's fighting them because he used the
the flaming you label and the the chain
scythe to smash exactly bone man so I
mean which kind of disease hello you
know it feeds into the burn the mall
kind of thing yeah so the show's writers
are dropping really clumsy heavy-handed
hints that the tallies are going to have
some kind of big resurgence I have a big
part to play in the latter half of this
season um they keep dropping the name of
the blackfish who's retaken Riverrun and
they've also just you know hidden years
alive you know hey kids remember me nope
no we don't know who are you no I am I
remember idea but it's you've been gone
a long time so I thought it'd be helpful
to have another refresher in why these
guys are so important so let's start
with the blackfish himself he's been
seeded the longest I think so he's
bringin tully he's Catelyn Stark's uncle
the younger brother of hosta Tully who's
captain's dad and he's a distinguished
night and he's been married to the job
he's quite been a successful military
tactician
but he's never married so and even
though his brother has set him up with
some fine ladies he loves the fishes
he's he's the blight so hid the reason
he's for black fish is because he's the
black sheep of the family and because
the Tully's love fish he's the black
fish and it's stuck it's also the name
of a very harrowing documentary on
netflix about sea world but so he's
called he's got the blackfish uh and in
Game of Thrones as we seen him he's been
he know he counseled Rob back when rob
was leading his king of the north king
of the north stuff he's eventually you
know quite unsuccessful king of the
north stuff and he warns catlin just
about how slippery and how dangerous
Walder Frey is so basically he's the
only Tully who's been speaking since
yeah that's what makes him the black
sheet yeah yeah um he's also like the
world's luckiest man because at the red
wedding he drank too much and needed to
pee and managed to escape at the exact
moment that the massacre started what a
time to go for a piss just perfect do
you think that was a coincidence a lit I
don't know maybe he's got like some fish
sense that tells him like he was just so
scared just like he was wetting himself
he's not gonna have it okay gotta go um
I don't know in Game of Thrones I don't
believe in coincidence anymore I like to
think that he I don't know would he know
like even if you did know what he know
what I mean if he's if he's already
warning people duh you know Walder Frey
is not a wholesome dude like he might be
getting a feeling like I don't let this
man I gotta go and I go pee on a tree he
heard the rains of castamere Nia's like
I'm out peace reigns he was like oh you
be happy flushing meadows uh so where
he's been in the last couple seasons
he's been rebuilding the Tully army and
as we know from Littlefinger who's a
trustworthy source for a change he's
taken river run back the homeland of the
Tully's from the phrase which is awesome
so we also know the Brienne of Tarth is
on her way to go and treat with him and
try and get support for son Cesare me up
in the north but what I am thinking now
is that now we know that Jaime
Lannister's on his way is he gonna have
men to spare like I assume Jamie's gonna
bring the Lannister hordes they're gonna
have
whatever support is left from the phrase
I don't know if he's managed to make
build them any men yeah I'm not too sure
Eva I mean not likes the phrase either
even the lannis as well as they're meant
to be allies and the whole reason like
phrase were like oh I'm gonna kill your
enemies in one fell swoop Lannisters
because he was meant to marry my gross
door and now he's not so screw those
guys but maybe like you mentioned
Brienne mmm we saw Brianna and Jamie get
quite close mmm I on don't you dare take
dominate I think they're just they're
just good friends they're just good
friends David they became quite quite
friendly had a mutual respect region
yeah so if she turns up at the same time
maybe her and Jamie can work something
out like we see we know the phrase have
got a demure and the whole point of that
him they're having him is to use him to
break the siege hmm so that there's a
lot of characters in play all with kind
of their own agendas it's basically
gonna whose agenda is going to come out
on top yeah speaking read me let's have
a little brief reminder of him so he is
catlins brother and he's been as we
found out kept in a dungeon for the last
three seasons so he is you remember he's
the kind of more hot-headed emotional
Tully I guess they all are to a degree
but when when their dad died when hasta
died he had to you know like the the
funeral pyre on fire with a bow and
arrow could do it just kept missing so
that's when Brynden actually got
involved was like give me that he's a
little bit ashamed of his nephew in his
hotheadedness um so he's technically
ahead of house Tully and when Robb Stark
all he needed to do was marry Walder
Frey's daughter to secure that treaty
but instead he pissed him off and
married what was a name to Lisa Connie
remember whenever I think about I just
have that flashing image of the red
wedding in in Game of Thrones they have
the weird bedding ritual which is like
everyone being like yeah you're gonna
have sex and like he you know picked her
and Roslin Frey and admire and took them
up to their bedroom and then they just
capped
so he's just been sad there I always
assumed that they killed him yeah yeah
um so Edna is now bargaining chip I'm
coz yeah it doesn't seem it doesn't yeah
this doesn't bode well for him I mean is
anyone else gonna really care that they
look before you're dead already so um
don't care man i know i guess like house
Tully though they are they have strong
family ties but also I think
Littlefinger might care yeah because if
Littlefinger they all grew up together
so if little fingers aware which I'm he
probably is yes everything I see him
he's gonna at least maybe send the night
of the veil there maybe that's why
because Santa's already refused his help
so maybe he helps out there first and
then secures that Alliance and then they
all go up so is this whence answer
refused the troops mmm is that white
thing little fingers sewed like oh by
the way blackfish is ur so she knew he
should go that he knew he should go
there and in the stalemate that's gonna
come from like the the black Fisher's
troops and Jamie's troops and the fray
troops like little things just gonna
step in with his army of like super veil
night like listen out I'd like to see
that happen now's the part of the show
where we tend to do death of the week no
one of note died nice we know they're
all nameless already dead White's so we
thought instead we would do hat of the
wheat bread our passes week there have
been some pretty great hats I think we
have a clear winner yes but let's let's
talk about something other gray hats I
mean the Mad King yeah ethical crown huh
there's like dragon wings oh and it was
like screaming as well as I was like
worrying that you work in that hat and
of course honorable mention to Olenna
Tyrell her hats always go away zone
point all those great but I mean the
real winner just take about mace Tyrell
magnificent kids I mean your speech was
a solid 4 out of 10 yeah aha that's the
thing like he gave her an awful speech
but everyone of the true spot like that
hat though yeah don't listen they're
like no like she's talking rubbish but
he looks good doing it majesty of that
has a beautiful hat like I wish I could
I had the balls to wear a hat like that
just on add a random day I would do it
so come in next week yes wearing a hat
like feathers and stuff in it just
typing away on my desk take a bow miss
Tyra time now for a separate spoiler
warning if you didn't watch the next
time on game of thrones and you want to
go into next week's episode completely
fresh look away now turn off you know
close your window but we're gonna be
talking about the promo for season 6
episode 7 the broken man the promo
starts with our black fish and Jamie
having a like butting heads having a
little face off which is good because
they spent the last three episodes
seeding that the black fish is gonna be
a thing damn it like you should you
should get ready you should get hyped
for him what does he say he says as long
as I'm standing also they make a big
thing of Walder rivers who is the guy
who I think cut cat's throat um I guess
the seating that he's gonna get his
comeuppance maybe um but then you know
move on to King's Landing let's get a
leaner and Cersei um Elena has a really
great like another amazing put down vez
se are two ancient houses face collapse
because of your stupid are we also get
to see badass Sansa back in the north so
she is visiting small houses with John
and Davos so we already know that house
mormont is loyal only to the stocks and
we can see them there you can see the
banners we also get to see a house
Glover so the Scarlet flag with the yes
in the background only glimpse of it but
we also know that they're loyal to
schnucks as well you see some Greyjoy
action we're going to take back the iron
Island so I assume they're on their way
they took that jet packs and they're in
volantis now so all those boats had jet
packs on board I mean the way that time
travel is time travel and traveling in
general is working i don't want to see a
whole season of just them on a boat just
traveling from one point how long oh
another six weeks it's the only
constantly complaining that he's been
castrated yeah we also see Tom and
Giantsbane talking to the wildlings be
like you know John died for us so I
guess that's that's the thing about
that's a scene he says he died for us if
we're not willing to do the same
cowards that could mean John more manse
romance writers they both died further
maybe but I mean I think its job I mean
yeah I mean the problem with Mance
Rayder is they cut a whole plot line
where there was like a wildling princess
and all that stuff and with Mance Rayder
they cut from the books i see him i just
took my job I think Tolman's just
sticking around to get a bit closer to
bran she's gone now she's on the
Riverlands like if he cuts ties with
them he can't see Aubree in again oh uh
and then speaking of Ed Mia he's uh good
well Walda rivers is holding a blade to
his throat so don't look good for him
can't catch a break back I've been stuck
in a dungeon like three years and now
he's a really bad bargaining chip
because nobody seems to care uh and then
we got a name drop of brawn in this
episode so there's no no dawn but at
least bronze back in the picture love
Bron Bron his back in town bronze back
in town Jamie's gonna find him and then
we get Davos for the sweet sweet line to
close the promo real war to be doing the
living and the dead and make no mistake
the data coming so that was episode 6
blood of my blood time what do you think
of it I do you know what the more I
think about it the more I kind of warm
to it was very messy the pacing was a
bit off the whole stuff of Sam was just
like uh but like it's setting up a lot
of interesting things cold hands I'm
very fond of mysterious assassin e-types
that appear out of nowhere and like I'm
really into that character but yeah it's
a lot of setup and not very lean episode
but like you shouldn't start it kind of
is what we needed after holding the door
last week Dave you've got a point with
Mike Mike said needs a diner back a
little bit but it was mostly filler yeah
yeah there are some good points there
are some points that we can look forward
to but we didn't need 15 minutes of an
old man calling his son fat I mean I
feel like at that point especially Sam
could have just gone in and been like yo
dad steal the sword and then go but I
guess they wanted to do some
characterization but I felt that it was
bad I want to see your dad telling the
Sun their fire I'd stay at home
my god well that's all for this week
don't forget to find more gamespot if
owns youtube com / gamespot you can also
find us on iTunes if you like the audio
version free commute or you know just
before bed listen to podcasts before go
sleep I just search itunes for gamespot
of Thrones you can find us here next
Monday of course we'll be running down
running through the next episode shall
be the broken man is that bran we're
gonna see what's in the Tower of joy
come experience the inevitable
disappointment with us when they get to
the door of the tower of joy and just
close it but in the meantime i'm on
twitter least james games dave i'm on
twitter at a regular dave and i'm at two
more h mm-hmm and we will see you next
week
you